astronaut scott kelly holds the u.s.
record for time spent in space in March
2015 he blasts it off for the
International Space Station where he
logged a record through 340 continuous
days in orbit while executing his
regular duties he also took time to
capture some incredible images of planet
Earth as well as life aboard his
orbiting home they're collected in the
new photo book infinite wonder and
astronauts photographs from a year in
space I had the chance to talk to Scott
Kelly here in New York the engines
igniting just before his launch into
space in 2015
astronaut scott Kelly got a shout-out
during President Obama's State of the
Union address Scott Kelly will begin a
year-long stay in space so good luck
captain and liftoff the year in space
starts now Kelly kornienko and padalka
on their way towards the International
Space Station
Kelly would take the president's
Instagram challenge to heart on his
fourth mission into space from 250 miles
up he would point his camera at the
planet you know with that long wind-up
cyou feel a little bit connected to the
earth when you could see yeah very well
see what's going on down there in some
ways Kelly has collected those space
photographs in his new book infinite
wonder the reason I put that picture in
there I think it really gives a sense of
perspective when you're in the on the
space station for how if when you're
looking straight down how close the
earth might might appear and then you
see continents and countries without any
political borders it gives you the
impression that you know we're all in
this thing called humanity together it
offered a unique vantage point on the
vastness of it all from Manhattan to the
Milky Way makes you feel kind of
insignificant doesn't it absolutely
actually the whole experience makes you
feel insignificant on this mission Kelly
would spend 340 days in space I believe
in the importance of
I in space and you know the research we
do some of his photography was for
scientific purposes but most was for his
own pleasure but sometimes it was as
simple as hey that spot looks a little
interesting down there you know some dry
lakebed and iran is an example let me
take a picture of it and see what it
looks like through his lens he found a
lake in Bolivia wetlands in Brazil
Mountain meeting desert in Algeria these
valleys full of iron ore and manganese
in Libya a lake in Western Australia
some of the landscapes almost look like
abstract paintings yeah that's what I
that's kind of what I wanted them to
look like Kelley became a master of
microgravity photography so how
difficult it actually was it to take
those pictures so you're looking at a
small spot on the earth and the earth is
going by at five miles a second you know
it takes a very steady tracking motion
to be able to take a picture that's not
blurry a lot of people when they first
get the space you're very clumsy it's
interesting when you see a bunch of new
astronauts show up they're like bounce
it off the walls it's stuff flying all
over the place the book also offers a
look at life in space you look very
comfortable here
yeah I'm floating that's me outside the
space station on a spacewalk oh look at
this guy yep
this is my brother this is my brother
losing on celebrity jeopardy to Aaron
Rodgers and you're watching up in space
Oh watchin em Kelly who now has well
over a million Instagram followers
shared many of his photos online was
great because you could see you could
see the reaction you would get from
people you can see the comments I would
read the comments sometimes one follower
commented on the plants he was growing
on the space station some guy said you
are no Mark Watney referring to the guy
in the Martian the botanist that you
know saved himself by growing potatoes
and after that you know fights on I was
gonna do whatever it took to make those
flowers look better
he succeeded and posted this picture to
prove it is this you coming back this is
coming back
looks pretty peaceful floating down to
earth until you crash into it he
returned with a new perspective on his
home planet God Kelly back on Mother
Earth after 340 days in space as a
fellow astronaut told him the earth
never disappoints there's a beautiful
place whether you know you're looking at
it you know all in one view or with a
really up-close lens
speaking of lenses he landed with his
glasses on yeah you know it's funny he
didn't he didn't take himself seriously
as a photographer until he had to train
to do it because you do it to record
things in space and then he was and then
he just took off and he became he's a
terrific photographer the pictures are
so inspiring it also inspires young
people to see what life is like for him
and Speights as an astronaut yeah yeah
beautiful talented beautiful you've got
one heck of a job yeah just like that